the myth of overnight success stories is
it really a myth it's mostly a myth a
friend of mine who just got a big
overall deal at a studio said oh it only
took me 14 years to be an overnight
success and that's the way it usually is
people put in a lot of hard work before
they become successful papers and
websites love to talk about overnight
success because really sexy but the
truth is it's not really happening
except there are exceptions there's
people like Mickey Fisher who was a
playwright on the East Coast and he was
just scraping by and decided that he was
going to write a couple of pilots and a
pilot he wrote ended up winning a
contest ended up being represented by
William Morris Endeavor ended up going
to Steven Spielberg's company ended up
having a 13 episode on the air
commitment and Steven Spielberg as the
executive producer
now that was sort of an overnight
success but that's one in a million
mostly it's just slogging away doing the
work during the work getting better
getting better getting better and
overnight success is the thing of movies
actually more than real life well you
know I was hearing an author speak the
other day I think it was a YouTube video
and they said that sometimes people with
incredible talent it's actually more of
a detriment because they come to LA and
they think well because I've been told
all my life I'm so fantastic right just
gonna be just less than a year right and
I'm gonna open doors right and they get
very frustrated and actually give up
more but I think that's true I think and
or you can meet with early success and
then have a fallow period Sean Ryan who
created the shield he was in Vermont in
college and he won a national award for
his playwriting he got to go to a on
they flew him to the west coast he sat
in a comedy writing room he was pitching
they bought an idea of his they hired
him the next
season on it and as he says I don't know
what everybody's talking about this
being difficult this was easy and then
he didn't work again for about six years
so the people who that have that
experience if this is so easy it it
often doesn't continue unfortunately
sometimes it does but often not right
and I think - don't you think younger
people they they they're they're more
seen as like these darlings and then
when you come here there's so many
darlings ah that have come as a friend
of mine also said in a cot in a
television comedy writing room you are
in a room with everybody in the room was
the funniest person in their class and
so suddenly you're not the darling
suddenly you're one of ten people who
were all the top of their class in terms
of being the class clown in terms of
being the funniest person at a party so
Hollywood brings the best of the best
and it's an adjustment people have to
make
you